well it's a great pleasure to be here
and introduce Vincent and Tandy and also
to welcome all of you for coming on this
cold and windy spring afternoon Vincent
and Tandy is an associate professor of
history at Montgomery College in Takoma
Park Maryland he is also the founder of
the Center for Black Studies at
Montgomery he received his PhD in
history in American University in 2009
after completing a BA in economics at
SUNY Potsdam and an MA in history at
SUNY Oswego in addition to his primary
appointment at Montgomery professor
entendi holds a position at American
University in the very year in which he
received his PhD he was named the
director of research for American
University's nuclear studies Institute
in Washington DC as a director of
research professor and tandy annually
teaches in Hiroshima and Nagasaki
alongside atomic bomb survivors nuclear
policy experts and various dignitaries
prior to teaching at Montgomery College
professor and Tandy was an associate
professor of history at Seminole State
College in Florida in 2011 he was named
distinguished Visiting Scholar of
african-american studies at Rollins
College where he co-created the Harry
team or Legacy Program to honor and
sustain the work of one of the early
founders of the civil rights movement as
his position at various colleges and
universities makes clear he has had in
the very short time since his PhD a
fertile affect on the institutions where
he has taught professor Anton D is rake
a regular contributor to The Huffington
Post and has appeared publicly alongside
Benjamin jealous
Bobby Seale Julian Bond Tom Hayden
Daniel Ellsberg Peter kuznick and Oliver
Stone most important for us this
afternoon he is the author of the book
African Americans against the bomb
nuclear weapons colonialism
and the black freedom movement published
by Stanford University Press this winter
and Col Harrison has kindly bought
copies of the books for us if you don't
already have one I first became aware of
this book several months before it would
peered and print when I happened to see
an advertisement in the Boston review I
can honestly say that I have seldom had
the electric response to a book
announcement that I had when I saw this
one why was that here's a partial answer
I think anyone who works on nuclear
weapons must see and must live with the
dreadful silence about our own genocide
'el weapons that rain in this country
our newspapers don't talk about them our
governors don't talk about them our
population doesn't talk about them yet
every once in a while I would see that
someone was saying something and not
just saying something but doing
something and not just doing something
but doing something that was about five
standard deviation deviations away from
what the rest of us were doing when
Jesse Jackson ran for president 1988 he
made no first use a plank in his
presidential platform a phenomenally
courageous courageous thing to do most
Americans then like most Americans today
don't know that we have a presidential
first use policy but here with someone
not simply pointing it out not simply
saying it was wrong but saying that it's
elimination would be a major objective
of his presidency his announcement was
the headline that day in the LA Times I
had a similar experience when I had a
very small part in a legal case against
presidential first use that involved
congressional plaintiffs who stepped
forward as the plaintiff in the case
Ron Dellums the african-american
congressman from the 9th District of
California in both cases I felt I was
seeing something miraculous but I didn't
know what I was seeing and what I was
seeing was the small tip a
an iceberg and professor Anton D's book
reveals the massive iceberg the massive
iceberg of anti-nuclear resistance and
responsibility so I was thrilled when
the mahindra humanity Center and the
Hutchins Center for African and
african-american research invited
professor Anton D to speak the Mellon
series on violence has had an array of
important conferences and an array of
marvelous solo speakers Steve Pinker
Etienne Bala Barr Bianca Jagger and
Vincent and Todd Lee then younger than
most now joins them finally I want to
say that I'm glad this lecture is
occurring on April 20th one week from
today in New York begins the review of
the non-proliferation treaty article six
of the treaty requires the nuclear
States to disarm and you can read more
about this in tomorrow's crimson by an
op-ed piece by PhD student Rebecca
Castleman and undergraduate Abel cover
this coming Sunday April 26 people will
be gathering in New York from many
countries around the world
to insist that the nuclear States disarm
the second reason is that today is
patriots day professor and tondee's
research is laced with patriots and as a
reminder of our obligations as citizens
citizens both of this country and
citizens of the earth
Muhammad Gandhi had a good explanation
for why people remain silent in the face
of manifest wrongdoing he said you can
wake a man who's asleep but you can't
wake a man who's pretending to be asleep
professor and tondee's book is a gift to
our country because it shows us people
and our people who never went to sleep
thank you
thank you it's a matter to be here and
before we get started there are a lot of
people I would like to thank for making
this event possible and of course to
start with professor Elaine Scarry but
also Sara Razer Susanne Smith Steven
Beal the mohandro Center for Humanities
the Hutchins Center for African and
African American research and my friends
at mass P section I'd first like to
begin by telling you all how this
project actually began because it's 10
years in the making in 2005 I made my
first trip to Hiroshima and Nagasaki as
a graduate student and up to that point
all of my academic career and my career
as a social political activists had
revolved around issues with civil rights
of the black freedom movement when I
went to Hiroshima no 5 and met with
atomic bomb survivors
I was so fundamentally changed so angry
so full of guilt that when I came back I
thought there has to be a way where I
could start to combine these two
passions of mine which was trying to
eliminating eliminate racism and doing
something about the issue of nuclear
weapons and so I started with one simple
question
what did African Americans think of
dropping the atomic bombs on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki and when I started asking
colleagues about this question over and
over they told me you're probably not
going to find much that
african-americans were too busy and
understandably so trying to gain their
own freedom and equality that they
didn't have time to worry about nuclear
weapons what they were wrong on June 6
1964 a group of Japanese peace activists
writers and atomic bomb survivors run a
world peace study mission they visited
five other countries and then made their
way to the United States the woman in
charge of arranging their visit in the
United States was an amazing
japanese-american activist Yuri
Kochiyama who he just lost last June and
when they were with her in Harlem she
said
to them while you're in the United
States what is it that you would like to
do when you're here and they all said
the one thing they wanted to do most was
meet Malcolm X but at the time Malcolm
was traveling in the Middle East and in
Africa and while she was friends with
him she started writing letters to his
office thinking none of them actually
got to him and the last day they were
having a reception in her house and
there was a knock at the door when she
answered it there stood Malcolm he came
back and he said to them you have been
scarred by the atomic bomb but we've
also been scarred in this country and
the bomb that hit us was racism he then
would spent the day explaining to them
how the war in Vietnam and how
imperialism colonialism freedom and
peace were all interconnected because
Malcolm understood what so many before
him understood that the issue wasn't
about civil rights the issue was
universal human rights and he knew how
these things were inextricably linked so
my book my research examines those black
anti-nuclear activists who often
connected the black freedom movement
here with liberation movements around
the world and the struggle for peace and
nuclear disarmament now if we look at
the scholarship with african-american
history in this country for so long
textbooks and scholars have separated
african-americans from the entire
American narrative February comes and
let's jam as much as we possibly can in
for that one month and that covers Black
History look at our kids textbooks and
there's a picture of Martin Luther King
and a nice neat little categorical box
or Rosa Parks and that covers black
history and I'm hoping that my research
will stop that and will show people that
the United States the narrative of US
history and the narrative of
african-american history cannot be
separated and this whole mission comes
despite the fact that if you look at the
urban concentration and population of
African Americans if there was ever a
nuclear attack you could argue that
they're more in danger than any other
group of people in this
and so I started asking a series of
questions
what role did it play for African
Americans that the victims of the first
nuclear attack were non-white I asked
what role did it play and how African
Americans were being treated in this
country and did that caused a more
critical critique of u.s. foreign policy
in the Cold War
what role did the black Popular Front
and leftist groups in this country play
in looking at this issue and over the
last decade we have seen more studies in
African American history examine the
role of African Americans in u.s.
foreign policy the role of African
Americans and Foreign Affairs and
scholars have now concluded in many
cases that African Americans have been
involved in international issues in
Foreign Affairs dating back to the 30s
and 40s with a much more pan-africanist
approach whether it's looking at how
they view the Italian invasion of
Ethiopia or the Bandung conference and
Indonesia but with a lot of these
scholars and a lot of the scholarship
the the general argument is that a lot
of this internationalism ends in the
1950s when McCarthyism hits that anti
communism was so horrible so bad that it
severs many connections in the black
community with international affairs and
we don't see this reimburse till the
Vietnam War especially with dr. King
where my research differs from these
scholars is that if you specifically
look at the atomic bomb if you look at
nuclear disarmament and pivot around it
you will see that yes in the 1950s
connections were weakened and groups
were destroyed but they were not these
links were not severed and that actually
they remain through the 1950s into the
60s 70s 80s and Beyond when on August 6
1945 when Harry Truman dropped in the
military dropped the atomic bomb on
Hiroshima and still he killing 140,000
people and then on August 9th and not
sake killing 70,000 people instantly
majority of the American public rejoiced
not because they were celebrating go
quicker into the war but they wanted
revenge for Pearl Harbor indeed in this
country after Pearl Harbor there was as
many scholars have noted a genocide oh
race hatred against the Japanese that is
unparalleled in our country's history
even more so than any hatred towards
people of Middle Eastern descent after
9/11 model of the Marines at the time
was remember Pearl Harbor keep him dying
General Joseph Stilwell wrote to his
wife what I think about these bowlegged
cockroaches have ruined our calm lives
it makes me want to wrap Jap guts around
every lamppost in Asia magazines and
newspapers and every ad that we saw
depicted the Japanese as being Apes and
vermin cockroaches and why makes
somebody less than human make a group of
people less than human and it's easier
to commit this mass violence against
them no different than what we did to
during the United student the
transatlantic slave trade and we don't
do this with other groups of people if
you look back we're very careful to
separate Germans from Nazis Italians
from fascists but not Japan everyone was
guilty
in fact Gallup did a poll a week after
the atomic bombings that showed 85% of
the American public agreed with Truman's
decision to use nuclear weapons a Roper
poll two months later showed that 22
percent of the American public wished
that Japan hadn't surrendered so he
could have dropped more nuclear weapons
and killed more people and in fact no
poll up until late October in 1945 ever
showed more than 4.5 percent of the
American public disagreeing or
criticizing Truman's decision but this
wasn't the case in the black community
this issue brought together artists and
activists and journalists and clergy
musicians athletes and they didn't wait
for any organized peace movement to
begin and it wasn't all monolithic it
wasn't all for the same reason some
looked at this and said we could just
have a more peaceful world without
nuclear
others it was because they were involved
in the black Popular Front and tied this
to colonialism and others were looking
at the atomic bombing through the lens
of race now some of this immediate
criticism of Truman's decision actually
predates the atomic bomb because there
was already in many cases in affinity
with the Japanese people there was it
was the Japanese who publicly came out
and said they were going to come to the
aid of Ethiopia when Italy invaded
African Americans in many cases looked
at Japanese internment and said here are
a group of people being put in prisons
for no crime they committed but just
because of the color of their skin could
this not happen to us we know that there
were Japanese agents actively here
trying in the black community to get
support of course they went after Elijah
Muhammad in the Nation of Islam later
it's why and so much of their literature
they referred African Americans is the
Asiatic black man back Malcolm X when he
was in front of the draft board one of
the things he did say was that he would
be in favor of Tokyo so we have this
affinity already there in some cases and
so when I started to look at this one of
the first places I went was the Black
Press papers like the Chicago Defender
the Pittsburgh courier Baltimore
afro-american where african-americans in
night in the 1940s were getting a lot of
their information from and
overwhelmingly what I saw were columnist
and editors criticizing Truman's
decision referring to the atomic bomb as
a ghastly war weapon diabolical warning
it could end civilisation but I didn't
want to just get with the editors and
columnist were saying I wanted to get a
feel for what the general public was
saying in the black communities so I
started going through letters to the
editor now the students here back then I
didn't have the luxury of going on a pro
quest putting in a couple keywords and
hitting search I was in the Library of
Congress with microfilm going through
issue by issue day by day looking at
every letter to the editor and again
what I found was a pattern while there
were struck drivers or beauty shop
owners or teachers or domestic workers
over and over I saw criticism of
Truman's decision
to use the atomic bomb even prominent
individuals started speaking out
Langston Hughes writing in the Chicago
Defender was one of the first to
publicly come out and ask what role race
played in this decision and he was valid
to do so President Truman was if not the
most certainly one of the most racist
presidents in US history this is a man
that if you read his letters to his wife
best go through his personal Diaries go
through his journals he rarely refers to
african-americans as anything other than
the n-word he brags in interviews that
in his family you got slaves as wedding
presents to start out the housekeeping
with his mother openly supported the
Confederacy and when she first visited
him at the White House that she'd rather
sleep on the floor than ever stepped
foot in Lincoln's bedroom and when he
was told that the first atomic bomb was
dropped instantly killing over a hundred
thousand people the first thing he did
was jump up and say quote this is the
greatest thing in history of course this
is the history that we don't learn in
bad Gary Sinise films and bad David
McCullough biographies and so we have to
dig around for this kind of history of
Harry Truman Zora Neale Hurston who many
argue is very apolitical throughout her
career was certainly not on this issue
on a letter she wrote to her friend
Claude Barnett in which she referred to
Harry Truman as quote the butcher of
Asia and was visibly upset that more
people in the black community were not
rising up and speaking out against this
issue with the initial criticism easily
the most vocal came from the black left
most notably w eb Du Bois and Paul
Robeson Du Bois of course had been to
Japan previously where he was lionized
in many ways he came out immediately and
compared Truman to Hitler calling him
one of the greatest killers of our day
he said that the atomic bombing of a
colored nation in Japan will setback
other non-white nations and people for
years to come a year later Paul Robeson
and a massive rally of the Council on
African affairs at Madison Square Garden
20,000 people there
Robeson immediately went after the
colonialism issue asking where is the
United States getting the material in
the uranium to build nuclear weapons and
the answer to that of course was the
Belgium controlled Congo I'm so thrilled
that Steve McQueen the director of 12
years of slave has agreed to make a
biopic of Paul Robeson because he is so
forgotten in our history such an amazing
individual that my students so often
have never even heard of but this
immediate criticism dramatically changed
in the late 1940s with the Truman
Doctrine long before george w bush ever
said with us or against us it was truman
who laid that line in the sand and said
you are with us or against us and when
that happened one of the worst things
you could be in this country was to be
labeled black and red and so yes many
groups fell mute others like Walter
White and the n-double-a-cp the
organization to voice out found made a
dramatic shift to the right on this
issue now part of that was strategic
they felt that if they stop criticizing
foreign policy and stop criticizing
Truman they'd be rewarded with civil
rights a bargain that never comes to
fruition other activists in the black
community though didn't look at peace as
a bargaining chip because they saw where
this was going the arms race was on the
Soviets catch us in 1949 and create the
atomic bomb the United States gets the
hydrogen bomb in 52 the Soviets get it
in 53 and now it's a full-blown arms
race not only that we also had to break
a break out of the Korean War when the
Korean War happened
President Truman senators on both sides
of the aisle various members of our
Defense Department all came out and
publicly said we should use nuclear
weapons in Korea again on a people of
color and so activists in the black
community said no we cannot remain
silent and let this happen again
and at the same time there was a peace
movement reah merging but it was out of
communist bloc countries and out of
Stockholm came what's now known as the
ban the bomb petition du Bois Robeson
their wives and others made a conscious
effort to get signatures of the banned
the bomb petition in this country it
focused on the black community they got
over 2.5 million signatures Marion
Anderson Duke Ellington Charlie Parker
all signed over a hundred million signed
around the world and when we talk about
a band the bomb petition especially if
I'm talking to students today it's big
deal because yes we can go on Twitter we
can go on change.org and the safe
security of our homes and 1-click we've
signed a petition and done our activism
it was a different story back then to
sign a petition like this to a real
consequences people are physically
beaten for signing this they lost their
jobs for signing this their boys was
brought up on charges of being a foreign
agent of the US government not guilty of
course and so to see this that on the
the beginnings of the civil rights
movement and with all of this fear of
anti-communism to see the black
community come together and millions of
people willing to sign this petition
saying they wanted to outlaw nuclear
weapons is extraordinary and where all
of this started to go in the 1950s was
what's known as the Sahara Project so
many things were happening in there
early in mid 1950s at a very rapid clip
you have of course in 54 brown v board a
year later the heinous murder of Emmett
Till a few months after that Rosa Parks
refusing to give up her seat on a bus
well many people forget is in that same
year was the Bandung conference in
Indonesia the first all Asian African
conference that had a platform focused
on eliminating racism and colonialism
and nuclear weapons
and by the late 1950s all signs all
roads were leading to Algeria in Africa
I'm happy that some of my students are
starting to discover by Ruston from this
film Selma of course by Ruston though
has such a long and rich history dating
back to the 1930s of activism in this
country but so many marginalize him and
iced him out of movements and literature
because he was openly gay and Rustin was
such a key figure in this research but
Ruston like so many others during this
time were kind of trapped because a lot
of his work was with peace groups that
were dominated by white middle-class
pacifists when many ways carry their own
prejudice their own deep-seated racism
that he had to navigate through and so
in the late 1950s with all of this
happening the French government
announces they were going to test their
first nuclear weapon and where the
Sahara at the same time you have Kwame
Nkrumah and an independence movement in
Ghana the people in Ghana were
especially scared because of the fallout
what it could do to the cocoa industry
and as the fourth Republic was falling
as Algeria was fighting for independence
Rustin saw this and said this is it
civil rights here we have this fight for
independence in Africa now we have the
nuclear weapons testing it's all coming
together it's all linked together and
his goal was to stop the French test so
he puts a group of activists together
both British and American and heads to
Africa to work when the kroombit I try
to stop this test not everybody was
happy here a philip Randolph was furious
he wanted Rustin here to work on civil
rights Rustin was trying to say to him
don't you see how these things are
connected and so Rustin goes there and
with various activists tried multiple
times to stop the French but sadly in
February of 1960 the French government
tested their first nuclear weapon in the
Sahara the continent exploded in
protests
and while many would argue it's a
failure on Ruston's part I would say no
was a success because he brought such
attention to it that nakooma stayed with
this issue and continued with world
without the bomb conferences non-violent
conferences and there was so much
pressure on France that eventually they
did abandon their tests groups like
Seine and committee for nonviolent
action white pacifist groups now were
popping up all over especially in this
country in the late 1950s early 60s but
what I saw was overwhelmingly the the
the people that were endorsing their
advertisements were appearing for them
the ones that were getting the biggest
crowds and the most attention we're
always African American Harry Belafonte
and of course dr. King now dr. King were
starting to see far too long in coming
but we're starting to see more and more
of an examination of the radical side of
dr. King especially that last year of
his life scholars are trying to are
writing more work that's looking at this
and it's in Kings critique of capitalism
and the Vietnam War but again what many
argue is that King was speaking out
against u.s. foreign policy starting
largely with his beyond Vietnam speech
on April 4th 1967 but if you look at
this issue nuclear weapons you will see
that actually he was critiquing this as
far back as 1957 ten years earlier he
came out in 1957 publicly saying he was
against nuclear weapons and thought they
should be banned
whether it was speaking at colleges like
Spelman are speaking to the black clergy
over and over he was saying the same
things that nuclear weapons needed to be
banned whether it was looking at the
money being spent on them and how it
could be better spent in his community
or simply saying what is it matter if
we're using the same waterfowl and if
we're all dead from nuclear war it makes
no sense
and where was King learning this from
his wife mostly Coretta was a long
season activist dating back to her days
at Antioch College she had worked with
women's strike for peace and women's
international league of peace and
freedom but again like Rustin for black
women working in these groups they had
to deal with the internal racism there
was a conference in Detroit for women's
strike for peace in which black
delegates black women were going to
carry signs that said disintegration or
desegregation and the leadership the
white leadership a woman's strike for
peace were completely against this do
not want to merge these issues saw these
as single issues and was often Coretta
fled to play peacemaker in between and
she was not alone Lorraine Hansberry of
course we know of Raisin in the Sun was
a feminist radical anti-nuclear activist
she famously went into a movie theater
and saw a film called Hiroshima and came
out and was caught saying we must make
sure this never happens again we must
stop this and the last play that she
wrote that never was produced was
actually about a nuclear holocaust and
the two survivors who made it out and we
see this continue throughout the Vietnam
War because again multiple times the
United States threatens to use nuclear
weapons again not of people of color in
Vietnam the Black Panther Party if you
read executive mandate number one that
Bobby Seale read you will see that it
actually compares the black freedom
struggle here with colonialism and the
atomic bombings of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki and I talked to Bobby about
this and asked him if this was conscious
he said sure it was everything we did
was put into an international framework
and indeed Kathleen and Eldridge Cleaver
are both invited by Japanese activists
to go to Japan and speak about this
issue in the 1970s when so many people
were physically and mentally exhausted
from the struggles of the 60s this issue
remains there was what was called the
Continental walk for disarmament
supposed to be a peace march coming from
all different directions in the country
to meet in Washington DC and for most
areas it was a simple exercise except if
you were participating in the southern
leg
because the southern leg was dominated
by african-americans who were being
arrested there were death threats so
again it was much much more dangerous
for them looking at Jimmy Carter
President Carter's ambassador to the UN
Andy young who was dr. King's right-hand
man for so many years and it was Andy
Young who was pressuring Carter not to
build a neutron bomb it was Andy Young
who was so active in trying to make sure
the white apartheid government in South
Africa who was secretly building a
nuclear weapon with Israel gave that
program up and of course the height of
this activism really came in the 1980s
with President Ronald Reagan Reagan came
into office and he cut social programs
by a hundred and forty billion increased
military spending by a hundred and
eighty 1 billion twelve million children
were now officially under the poverty
line famously know now that a packet of
ketchup was now constituted the school
vegetable during his time at the Food
and Drug Administration and he wanted to
spend all this money on MX missiles and
Star Wars and more nuclear weapons and
so a campaign emerged especially in the
black community called bombs over babys
to try to highlight and show the money
that was being spent on nuclear weapons
in the Reagan administration and how it
could be better spent in their
communities again connecting these
issues and it came from all directions
when I was writing this book and writing
for the Huffington Post I got a phone
call from a gentleman who he said I've
been reading your stuff on Huffington
Post and following you and We Need to
Talk I was involved in this in the 1980s
so we met he gave me treasure trove of
documents and interviewed him and here
was just an african-american librarian
from Georgetown and then his wife at the
time in the 1980s we're saying we care
so much about this issue and we see
these connections why is nobody speaking
to us why are the none of these white
groups in our community talking about
this and they said the heck with waiting
for him we'll do it ourselves with a
rotary phone and one flyer they started
the group blacks against nukes which
grew to multiple chapters hundreds of
members they were featured in Ebony and
jet in essence magazine they were asked
to go to Japan and speak in Hiroshima
ordinary people doing extraordinary
things I'm so thrilled that we're
starting again to see the rise of a
socially conscious athlete I taught for
four years at the same school that
George Zimmerman went to so I was
knee-deep in all the Trayvon Martin
organizing at the time and I was
thrilled to see LeBron James throw his
hood up before anybody else and also
speak out against Donald sterling it's
great to see athletes wearing I can't
breathe t-shirts and taking a stand when
it's politically inconvenient for them
and doing it anyways and then we all
remember where we were when Michael
Jordan at the height of his career was
famously asked why doesn't he do
anything about sweatshop labor and his
response was because Republicans were in
Nikes too and when we think of socially
conscious athletes we of course think of
Muhammad Ali and the 68 Olympics with
Tommie Smith and John Carlos raising
their fists there's another group of
athletes that we're also doing this kind
of work and they were called athletes
United for peace prominent black
athletes from the NFL and Major League
Baseball and the NBA coming together
some visiting Russia all under the
banner of trying to make peace Joe Joe
White of the Boston Celtics Marion
Washington the first african-american
female to play in the u.s. national
women's basketball team dude the whole
Baltimore Orioles one year went to Japan
went to Hiroshima to meet with survivors
this was all leading to the June 12 1982
March the largest March in some ways of
any March we've had in this country's
history where nearly a million people
came together against nuclear weapons
and researching that March again the
same friction was there in which white
groups wanted to make sure this was a
single issue we only focused on nuclear
weapons and african-americans are saying
no we want to tie this to what is
happening in El Salvador Nicaragua we
want to tie this to the money that could
be spent in our communities we want to
tie this to racism and reverend Herbert
Daughtry in New York put
grouped together the united black front
threatening to have a separate march
there was all sorts of friction and it
took people like Chaka Khan and Harry
Belafonte Ossie Davis and Ruby Dee to go
in and try to mesh this together and
finally get that leadership half of that
leadership to be african-american and to
have a successful Marshall what they did
which they did and so let me conclude
here for a moment speaking about
President Obama President Obama was
clearly the hardest part to write for me
to write this book as a historian the
worst thing I could do is predict
something and then it'd not be true so
I'd be very careful not to do that in
this book I also knew that I couldn't
shy away from President Obama for such
obvious reasons as the lane mentioned
the first thing to understand is how
many came before him not just activist
that I've briefly spoken about so far
but politicians like Ron Dellums the
Congressional Black Caucus shirley
Chisholm John Conyers Jesse Jackson who
is 84 and 88 campaigns were had a much
stronger anti-nuclear platform than
anybody else running and he garnered
millions of votes President Obama's one
of his biggest heroes Harold Washington
mayor of Chicago also staunch
anti-nuclear activists and President
Obama was against nuclear weapons or
writing or speaking out against him as
far back as his days when he was a
student at Columbia he campaigned on an
anti-nuclear platform when he got
elected he continued to speak out
against nuclear weapons and very soon
after his inauguration he gave what is
now known as the Prague speech the most
anti-nuclear speech of any president in
US history with possibly the exception
of president john f kennedy's
commencement address at american
university in June of 1963 dubbed the
peace speech and I remember going to
Japan as I go every year that year and
seeing the euphoria of the Japanese
people especially the survivors of the
bomb
I was walking around at the ceremony on
August 6 that year and Japanese citizens
were literally giving me stacks of
letters saying please go back and give
these to your president and thank him
for his Prague speech and what he's
doing and he continued on this
trajectory signing the New START treaty
to cut our nuclear arsenal by 30%
having 47 countries meet every four
years and successfully getting Chile and
Mexico and Argentina and Ukraine and
others to turn over their nuclear
weapons making materials that year in
Japan he had is our ambassador
ambassador Roos at the actual ceremony
first time any president did that and in
fact in Japan they actually started a
campaign called the Obama jority
campaign because they were so elated
with what he was doing there's always a
buck with Obama right it's the
frustrating thing we got health care but
we lost that public option he acted on
immigration but he deported more people
than any president in history and this
is more frustrating because on this
issue Obama didn't just stagnate he
actually went backwards when he got
re-elected we thought okay now that
there's no more elections he's going to
make that dramatic shift to the left
that John Kennedy did after the Cuban
Missile Crisis when he decided to go all
in on civil rights and finally try to
end the Vietnam War and make peace with
Cuba and Russia and the Cold War and we
saw President Obama put Chuck Hagel in a
defense and he had been a spokesman for
global zero so he said that was a
positive step we saw Caroline Kennedy is
the ambassador to Japan we said that
would be a positive step but then he
announced that he was going to take
money out of non-proliferation programs
and put it into building more nuclear
weapons now he decided to cozy up to
this radical right-wing Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a who will soon be in another
week visiting the White House and and
speak into a joint session of Congress a
prime minister who is now trying to edit
textbooks in Japan to make sure that you
trust
the Japanese military committed or
downplayed wants to change that
the amazing peace Constitution in Japan
wants to remilitarization expand the
military base in Okinawa which is
already horrific in terms of violence
and crime and rape and in the trade
agreement so it's so troubling and if
that's not bad enough Obama's new budget
now calls for spending 1 trillion
dollars over the next ten years on new
nuclear weapons and so you look at it
and you say well he acted on Cuba acted
on immigration and he just came out said
he wanted two years of free Community
College great first question was how you
gonna pay for it no 1 trillion on new
nuclear weapons and be a good place to
start and so what can we learn from this
well one I think the obvious is that we
can no longer separate the narrative of
US history and u.s. Cold War studies
from african-americans the other is so
often in this history we see African
Americans in the abyss and such misery
fighting for their own freedom and when
you see them wield their collective
power to make a more peaceful world it's
extraordinary
we can learn how all these movements are
connected all the kids and the groups
that I advise and work with on black
lives matter and all of these actions
now and explaining to them and showing
them how these movements are connected
that the very leaders they look up to
understood how these issues were
connected and so I don't know what'll
happen in the next year and a half with
President Obama
but I don't put that on him that's on us
he never said yes I can he said yes we
can and anything that he's done he's
been forced to act on immigrants forced
him to act on immigration the gay
community forced him to act on gay
marriage and if we really want him to
act on this then we have to be out there
forcing him to act on this issue and he
gets it when he was running for
president he was asked what dr. King
supports we said no he'd be in the
streets making me do what I said I was
gonna do so he gets it and I believe he
knows how these things are connected it
infuriates me when people say is he
black enough it's through diplomacy he
stops Iran from getting a nuclear weapon
and therefore the US or Israel do not
bomb Iran and we're not in World War
three how many non-white lives just do
that has he saved and it's no
coincidence that tomorrow I'll be back
in DC marching with my students with the
Justice League in the March to justice
against police brutality and then Friday
I'll be on a plane to March with Dan
Ellsberg and peace and Planet against
nuclear weapons they're connected and so
when we look at these issues to race
class where money is being spent then we
understand that like so many before him
Malcolm X was right and he said it best
that the issue has never really been
about civil rights for us the issue has
and always will be about universal human
rights thank you
many as you want
yeah but what is also interesting is
that in you'll see in the book that I
it's also like liberals this extends
beyond the black left especially when I
started looking at rank-and-file because
there is this issue of a lot of issues
do kind of get severed with the black
left in the 1950s but not this issue and
so it really does go beyond that
George Schuyler who certainly wasn't
part of the black left was openly
criticizing writing just going after
Truman with everything he had on this
issue
you see even people like Oh Gil
scott-heron the last poets there's I
mean you can go on and on with how many
people athletes I was speaking about
that certainly weren't members of the
black Popular Front writer at black left
so when you start examining this issue
it just starts you see how it hits
people in so many different ways and
again it's not always for the same
reason for the black left it really was
in many ways about colonialism and it
was about a larger worldview right but
for others they were just looking at
this and saying endure during the ban
the bomb petition there were you know
rank-and-file people in the community
that were being told you know you're
signing this and it's communist related
this is propaganda and there were people
saying they're coming out churches and
they said I don't care what it is I'm
not communist I don't care about
communism or they'll let I'm just saying
this because I don't want this bomb any
more it's got to go it's done
no more people of color being bombed
this is what I was seeing over and over
so it really does go further than that
but certainly they were in big positions
of leadership in various times no
question no question any other questions
yes
oh okay I'm interested in what kind of
rolls that you gave to Pacific Islands
and Pacific Islanders in in your story
because nuclear weapons testing during
the Cold War years is pretty much a
Pacific issue and I am also interested
in like whether you think about the
connection with the environmental
activism and nuclear world and
especially after here seaman Nagasaki is
the the issues of nuclear weapon sifted
to be increasingly became our
environmental and I am really curious
about your ideas on these two points
yeah great questions thank you yeah this
is a huge issue in fact I did a lot of
research on environmental racism and
nuclear testing and I didn't put in this
book it may be a different articles or
another book but so in terms of nuclear
testing one thing that I would see is I
would go into again black reporters and
see how are they reporting on this and
they were being invited to some of these
nuclear tests and what their reactions
were and was pretty horrific the other
piece though is the connection I saw was
African Americans who then themselves
were being used as nuclear guinea pigs
black GIS we're also being put in the
same and they were seeing that
connection there and saying were the
same ways what's happening here to test
and in the islands and so and this ties
into environmental racism as well that
for African Americans whether they were
black gi's were being used as guinea
pigs for nuclear testing and then not
being treated or told about the effects
just like in the in the islands or and
also the jobs that were available for
African Americans in certain areas was
so limited that they were the jobs were
in nuclear plants and they were not
giving any protective equipment and I
had wrote about this prerogative posts
and I started getting phone calls from
from family members of black GIS who had
passed away as a result of this at
cancer a seabirds family had called me
they had read a piece I wrote about him
and and I've been actively trying to get
recognition for both what has happened
in the in the Pacific with islands and
then also for African Americans and your
own one of your own congressmen here
locally has put forth a bill to try to
get recognition in a medal for black GIS
or
gi's in general that were used as guinea
pigs there's only been one formal
apology for what was done and that was
Bill Clinton but nobody really
recognized it because he apologized the
same day the OJ verdict was came out and
everybody's little preoccupied so but
certainly and and also you know
environmental racism in terms of nuclear
waste being dumped in certain black
communities poor communities all of that
is is relevant and ties into this and
Gil scott-heron had a great piece of his
liner notes about this comparing South
Africa to what was happening in the
black community with environmental
racism also tying the Native American
community in looking at Africa and
uranium depletion that all ties into
this and I think you can also tie it
into climate change right that that you
know I know there's there's been a lot
of divestment movement here on this with
Harvard but that there really is only
two things right now that can eliminate
us as a species and that is nuclear war
and global warming so I I see in a real
correlation there yeah with both yes
thanks very much for the presentation
I was just wondering to what extent
people of color whether that was a
unifying kind of identity or whether it
was relationships and alliances of
political convenience because I you know
i I've heard of pan-arabism and
pan-africanism but I haven't heard of a
global pan colorism and it seems
relevant particularly now at least on
this campus people of color as an
identity has been reemerging so I
wondered whether in your research you
saw the origins of that much earlier in
the way that these communities were
speaking with one another yes and and I
think you can go back and see that at
least I saw the evidence again you can
whether it is going back to Garvey and
then all the way up with ethiopian 35
and you go in the black pop to the front
of course but you also see this
throughout the civil rights movement the
black power movement we certainly had
this in the golden era of hip-hop in the
1980s people were in Africa medallions
and you had poor Wretch's teacher and
Afrika Bambaataa Zulu Nation and you had
such an afro centric focus even in music
at that time that dates back to the
Black Arts movement of the 60s it was
there
and so it's it's troubling that we don't
we have the disconnect there where I
teach now which is ran the border of DC
fifty percent of my students are
african-american forty nine percent are
African from all different parts of the
continent and then one percent other and
there is such a disconnect there now
where my African students will tell me
that they are taught in Africa to not
associate with African Americans when
they get here that African Americans are
lazy and they're not serious about study
so distance yourself from them and my
african-american students will say we're
not African we're not going to relate to
them and saying something like African
booty scratcher was a disc growing up so
we're not going to relate to that and
there's this disconnect and then to have
them realized that when a cop is beating
you he's not beating you because you're
African American or African or from
Ethiopia he's beating you cuz you're
black and to get them to realize that
even within my my African students my
Ethiopian students will say well we're
not from West Africa we weren't enslaved
we're Ethiopian so there's even a
hierarchy there and so you know finally
last year I remember there was a I was
in one class and we were talking about
Emmett Till and and I believe it was
when Eric Gardner when the verdict came
out there was not going to be an
indictment and one of my students from
Ethiopia stood up on her own kids were
crying and she said I finally get it I
get it that we're all black because in
class they would say they would refer to
other and they would say them they and
not realize that connection and so that
that anti-colonialism that idea of the
white West and who has the power whether
it's economically or militarily and how
these things are connected that is
something that we that we need and you
see that a really good example of that
when criticize government Snell was at
the turn of the century in South America
and when you had in South America was a
real in 2000-2001 a boulevardier and
revolution in which leftist leaders were
being democratically elected and with
Chavez's oil revenue money and you had
Abel Morales in Bolivia could hey an
Ecuador Kirchner in Argentina you had at
Paraguay Uruguay Lula and in Brazil they
were speaking with one voice using that
money to pay off their debts to the
World Bank and the IMF and say nobody's
going to tell us what to do and you know
for all the horrible things of course
that you can say of Qaddafi being a
despot and a monster
and all of that of course there are many
of my African students that will still
say the one thing he did want to do
though it wasn't sucessful as having the
continent speak with one voice and what
power would that be then in terms of
economics and so on and so forth
and so I yeah I think there's a great
film that's going to be coming out and
the in the fall
that's called bound and it looks at this
issue of African students in African
American students and how there's that
disconnect there so I think we really
need to get back to that and you know
that has to come from all venues we're
seeing it in hip-hop I'm thrilled with
Kendrick Lamar's new stuff and we're
starting to see you know that we're
starting to see it addressed a little
bit so yes thanks mitts and of course in
a half-hour presentation you cannot
include all of the granularity that's in
your book but I'm wondering in your
research what was your sense of how much
of this phenomenon mapped on to the left
or to put it differently did you not
find some anti-nuclear weapons sentiment
among black conservatives as well
well again George Schuyler I would argue
as conservative and and he certainly was
speaking out against this in his
writings but other than that I didn't
come across and I and I did try to look
at the entire spectrum but I didn't come
across a lot on the right that we're
looking at this which was surprising
excite frankly you know you obviously
you don't want to lead your research and
the research leads you but I was in many
ways I think the bomb doesn't
discriminate in some ways and that it's
I mean wanting to save humanity
shouldn't be a right or left issue but
it's the way it broke down but again I'm
looking at not all Democrats not all
Republicans that I'm looking
specifically at African that the black
community as much as I possibly could in
a large scope and what I saw was it
wasn't so much about politics it was
they're looking at this issue through a
completely different lens that others
weren't they were looking at this to a
lens of race through a lens of
colonialism and that did appear mostly
on people that were that lean
progressive that leaned on the on the
left but I don't I don't think it was
you know I didn't I did search but I
didn't see tons of black politicians
that were on the right coming out or
concerned
journalists coming out I didn't see that
well we we look at a litany of broken
agreements particularly with the u.s.
because we had Saddam pretty much at bay
and then they came up with
yellowcake while the UN inspectors were
in there and they trumped up the charges
and then they took out Saddam well they
took out a set of tried to take out
Assad and he took out Gaddafi and he was
playing ball and they still wanted to
get rid of him so and I think that has
to do with colonialism and politics of
that sort but with regards to Obama's
agreement with Iran the same thing could
happen there if I ran so much as steps
out of line
once they have the agreement and they
start backtracking then their backs are
against the wall
and I'm not saying they need nuclear or
it should develop nuclear but basically
it's a form of nuclear blackmail in
terms of the counter threat against them
not developing it is the destruction of
their potential of developing it in the
name of stability within the region and
I would contend that the possibility is
that the main destabilizer in the region
from the point of view of nuclear
weapons is Israel because they have 200
and what are they there for and isn't
anybody complaining about that and
telling them to get rid of theirs right
so there's a couple things that kind of
unpackage there and one is the obvious
that it is you have to look and say okay
how can he US or Israel for that matter
tell anybody what to do about nuclear
weapons in the region when Israel's the
only country that has them u.s. the only
one to actually use them terms of
blackmail if you're right
a friend Dan Ellsberg always says that
we can we use nuclear weapons all the
time in the same way that if you rob a
bank you can put them gone up to
somebody said you don't have to pull the
trigger and you can still get all the
money that you want I disagree with the
argument that if a country has nuclear
weapons if Iran had them and somehow
that makes them a more of a player or
keeps them
from from an attack from somebody else
we've just seen too many close calls
where we've just gotten lucky like with
the Cuban Missile Crisis so I don't
agree that that you know if everybody
has them then it'll just keep that over
them that's the solution but in terms of
Iran we have to take it one step at a
time and right now if this president
it's amazing to me if any other
president killed bin Laden and got Iran
to not build a nuclear weapon through
diplomacy he'd be on money right now
it's so we have to see how this plays
out it's unconscionable that that both
Democrats or Republicans are trying to
scuttle this in some way with an
agreement in Congress it really is when
the alternative is World War 3 and I
just think that you know it is something
where I'll have students even that are
very I think for a lot of people nuclear
weapons is abstract nobody's gonna be
crazy enough to use them even if people
have them and when I bring my students
to Hiroshima and they actually see what
it does it changes them it can't not
change you it's it's you know when
people say it look like a nuclear weapon
went off no it didn't
there's nothing like it nothing when a
nuclear weapon was off and it's why yeah
I really really am pushing hard right
now I'd been for a year
pushing publicly in my writing speeches
do we have President Obama go to
Hiroshima this year this is the 70th
anniversary his ambassador Roos said
that President Obama would go before his
presidency was over these survivors are
dying I've lost four or five that I that
I've knew him just in the last year or
two they're scared because they're
scared that they're gonna die and
nobody's going to carry on their message
they have said he doesn't need to
apologize just going there would make
all the difference in the world so now
is the time for him to go and so it's
but I don't know what the Shinzo Abe a
what this relationship is and if he
sells who don't go don't go
we know the rights gonna call them we
can apologist they do that now anyways
who cares but if he went it would be
absolutely extraordinary and so I think
we really have to push him every way we
can publicly to say now is the time this
is the year for him to go it would make
a world of difference towards marching
us in the right
direction well again I'm I'm not saying
that Israel isn't a concern and that we
shouldn't be content you know that that
yes there they could be a destabilizing
force in the region of course but I also
I'm trying to change my country's
policies and what my country is doing
here and and what I can you know whether
it's my students and so that's what I
focus a lot of that of the activist side
on and then there's the research side as
well yep thank you I learned a lot from
this talk was wonderful appreciate it
I'm curious I I heard you as arguing
that the solid areas between people
concerned about nuclear weapons reacting
to what happened in Japan and African
Americans that this was was building on
pre-existing solid areas between African
Americans and Japanese people but my
understand is that that that those solid
areas had had basically been fractured
and that that that had all fallen apart
that maybe 10 years 15 15 years earlier
people like Sarah Briggs had argued and
seen black people had argued that that
the Japanese Empire is an example to
follow but I had understood that during
the very ideological 1930s that all that
had crumbled and so I'm wondering if
that the drop of the bomb is is actually
an agent of pulling together
solidarity's rather than just a story of
continuity and then the question becomes
what what makes that likely and so one
question I have yeah I'm sympathetic to
the Arkham either saying that there's
nothing like a nuclear explosion but I'm
wondering if you mentioned Ethiopia if
the use of chemical weapons on black
people in in in Ethiopia in the night
that somehow readied black activists to
make that leap of solidarity and I'm
curious what what what what are the
origins of a black concern about the
nuke weapon does it come from concern
about chemical weapons or anything else
like that pre-existing or was this just
something completely complete novel the
first of your questions yes yes yes yes
and so the first thing is again to be
very clear nothing is monolithic right
so to say
the black community have to be very
conscious that so for example in terms
of Japan there was aspects where you had
legitimately black agents working again
whether it's the Nation of Islam are
working certain groups to try to flip
them that was happening okay
you also have take for Pearl Harbor for
example up until Pearl Harbor there was
a split there was in some cases there
wasn't if any that lasted that endure
past the 30s that continued to go and
this was in part from Du Bois writing
about the Japanese and black newspapers
to how they were looking at a colored
nations and so on and so forth but then
when Pearl Harbor happens there's a
split some were saying some of the black
newspapers are saying we are a hundred
percent committed we are as far away
from the Japanese as possible let's take
their jobs we wanted nothing to do with
them they're traitors those absolute
split there again others though we're
actually sneaking food into internment
camps and we're saying this could again
happen to us and we need to be conscious
of this so there's never one in terms of
the Japanese specifically one giant
thing and so even the bomb and the bomb
happens yes there are some they're
looking at this when they learn about it
even when the bombs dropped the the
newspapers start talking about African
Americans that helped make the bomb but
even in that they don't celebrate the
bomb like other newspapers what they say
is Oh our scientists are just as good as
whites and we can work with whites and
we're we're smart as them and so we
should be rewarded with this right and
in african-americans soldiers coming
back and saying well now we're going to
be rewarded with civil rights we put on
the uniform wrong and so they start
thinking differently about things what
were we fighting for and so I don't
think there's I didn't see one thing for
some again black left they immediately
started tying this to colonialism they
immediately started saying where's the
uranium coming from who possesses
nuclear weapons could dispute that other
countries now on non white countries
Africa is going to be next and so on and
so forth for others they were just
saying especially I started going
through the black clergy I started
looking at different pastor Sunday
sermons and they were all just saying
this is madness this is we don't have
enough religion to stop this this is
insane we and they said the genies got
to be put back in the bottle so they
were just looking at it through this
kind of apocalyptic narrative if you
will
Langston Hughes and again he wasn't
alone started looking at Samoan wait a
minute here what was the motivation Tara
was it truly to end the war
because or was there something else here
we know that that didn't in the end the
war was actually Russian Russian entry
that ended the war so and that's when
race starts being talked about Langston
Hughes starts asking these questions hey
why was it not dropped and why is it
being dropped onto people of color what
role the race play then it got other
people thinking going well okay wait a
minute well now maybe what wouldn't are
threatening Korea again now it's hurting
Vietnam seems to be a pattern here right
testing a nuclear weapon and ever wait a
minute why is it always non-white
peoples so I think there there isn't
just one answer to say that so I think
you're right in kind of looking at all
those things yeah those are all in
different aspects just trying to look at
different in terms of their economic
income rich african-americans poor where
they're living in the country were they
in the military where they journey you
know I tried to look at as many of that
as possible to try to really get a
larger scope of or a larger view of
where they were at I wondered if you
could just clarify something you said
right at the beginning you were talking
about I think the unique demonization of
the Japanese and you said we don't do
this to other people I don't know if you
meant at the time we didn't because I
immediately see the parallel to the the
contemporary demonization of Arabs and
so forth yeah as I mentioned yes we of
course did this during slavery we of
course did this after 9/11 what I'm
saying is in terms of especially during
wartime even the hatred towards people
in Middle Eastern descent after 9/11
doesn't compare to how bad it was during
during Japan in fact it's funny I have
people colleague students friends that
are reading my book and they'll say that
they're talking to a grandparent and
they'll say to her grandparent you know
wow we really had this hatred towards a
Japanese of course we did they should
have been back there's still this aging
when you go back and look at the media
the pictures during this time court John
dollars done great work on this you you
see that we're not doing this to the
Germans and to the Italians at this time
we're simply not but the Japanese the
whole country is guilty for this we're
not separating we're not saying there's
innocent civilians no they're fanatics
and again their military was horrible of
course it was it was brutal one of the
most brutal militaries that had to be
stopped
but of course it was stopped before the
bomb was dropped
we're already defeated you mentioned a
study of clergy sermons and I'm curious
if I'm sure there is more to say about
the the black church and its role then
and up to this point yeah well again in
the black church back in the 50s and 60s
was not in many cases preaching this
ridiculous prosperity gospel that we see
in many churches today pastors and
during the civil rights movement or
before that we're not caring about what
rims you had on your car and wearing
Armani suits they were preaching the
social gospel they were preaching a
gospel that to be Christian was to help
the poor that was your duty and so it
was very different in many cases and
they were seeing this again and they
were saying that that were so we're just
taking one evil and replacing with
another evil that's what we're doing
that with that again this is this we
don't have enough I don't have enough
faith to stop this that and looking at
this kind of again in this this could
end civilization is this it is this this
is the weapon and then looking at it
again we I would see black pastors
mentioning race and saying what role did
race play questioning the parishioners
and saying that that race discrimination
is there's no excuse to use something
like this so I would see it you know
repeatedly and then you know I didn't
see it so much in terms of 90s and and
so on and so forth after that but it was
early on that you saw in the black
church that's not to say it's not
continuing today and some aspects of the
black church again I'm gonna be with
Reverend Herbert Daughtry next week so
they're certain but you know there's
also other churches that we see today
they're much more concerned about wealth
and things of that nature and so I would
say we need to move away from that and
more towards focusing on and stuff like
this I was thrilled to see quite frankly
when we're talking about clergy to see
Pope Francis come out so vehemently
against nuclear weapons now and see what
he's what he's willing to speak out
against yes sir so I see that your book
and workings in general seem to be on
how knowing about the usage of nuclear
weapons seems to really gather up and
rally the black community to realize
that so these issues are coming together
and they need to
reach out to the other side and such but
is there also another site to the
dichotomy that you saw that in countries
that have been affected by the atomic
bomb by those in Japan somehow saw that
looked back at racism over here in
America and got out to the community
there and went to their other side of
the issue and thought about civil rights
there as a consequence of what happened
to them as well in terms of Japan and
civil rights I would say no in the sense
that even now my students so my students
in America we go July 30th to August
11th every year we go we partner with
Ritsumeikan University in Kyoto and my
students my Japanese students who love
hip-hop and they love shirts of Malcolm
X of Muhammad Ali on if you talk about
racism now they don't they don't know
that there's still this kind of
institutional structural racism going on
in our country okay that's number one
the other piece is Japan also atomic
bomb survivors we're gonna look at face
their own discrimination that's where
the comparison is that to be a victim of
the atomic bomb now you had the physical
deformity there was what's called the
Tomic bomb disease where doctors didn't
know why you were dying of cancer and
radiation and you also represented to
you represent a defeat so for a lot of
people they were being shunned and they
were facing discrimination and in the
same kind of way and that as dramatic as
is the structural racism in this country
towards people of african-american
descent so there's that comparison but
Japan certainly was not a even after
this there was issues of even today you
can look at how they look view black
face and how that should be viewed and
certain things of that nature
I think Spike Lee's film bamboozle
wasn't even allowed to be shown there
and so there's a lot of issues there
with race that still need to be
addressed when you when you're looking
at Japan and and how Asia also addresses
this so I didn't see this thing where
Japan was really big on civil rights and
knowing what was going on in the United
States and fighting for civil rights
here but that said just a couple weeks
ago it was a great article I believe the
New York Times Washington Post about
another Japanese man who was going he
Marsh at the original Selma March and he
marched again this time in 50th
anniversary
like I said mentioned Yuri Kochiyama was
certainly an amazing activist so but I
ain't seen though it was huge on the
radar in Japanese culture uh yeah a
couple of times you mentioned that Weiss
white peace groups had a divergence with
black peace activists on the cassette
and what I understood you to say was on
the question of should nuclear abolition
be a single issue or should it be linked
to racism should it be linked to foreign
policy should be linked to other social
issues then you said that those
divergences were resolved and how are
they resolved on what basis and did in
fact the white peace groups brought in
their agenda as a result of that
dialogue or what was that discussion yes
so for example sing
alright so sane emerges is a huge white
largely white middle class pacifist
group that was that was active and sane
realizes that they have a problem sane
realizes that they don't have a lot of
black members and that there are a lot
of rank-and-file or members and
leadership that don't want to merge
these issues and they're adamant about
it and there's other members insane that
are saying we have to merge these things
together like they're do not see that
there are these connections here between
civil rights and peace and so there's
this kind of back-and-forth going on and
I read the letters going back and forth
and it gets resolved in that they I
think it's it's moments there's it's
multi-dimensional that some are just
saying this is the right time the right
thing to do I think others are realizing
though that again it's prominent
african-americans that are bringing more
to the fold that they're bringing more
people into this and they're saying even
strategically this isn't a smart move to
just completely isolate
african-americans the black community
and say no we shouldn't be working with
them so there were a couple reasons for
it and you start to see it happen but
again there were those that were
adamantly against this and were you know
really hell-bent on not making sure that
this and again for some earlier on there
was this this prejudice as well though
it wasn't just a singular issue there
you I did see flat-out racism and some
of these letters going back and forth
and things like that or we don't want to
be as radical I'm and again this
new right we can go back to slavery and
you have the gradual Quaker approach of
let's wait or we have our own prejudice
then you got the John Brown's right you
got the John Brown type it's willing to
die for it right so there's always been
that kind of some that are willing to
only go so far in the white community
when it comes these issues and others
that are willing to go further and this
is just no different yep in some ways
yes but even then that also happens in
the black community though because when
dr. King begins to now speak out about
Vietnam and things in the late 1960s and
and still is combining these issues
Rustin in his and Kings views now
essentially become inverted right Rustin
now is against tying this to the Vietnam
War he's afraid of that communism piece
of it you feel brand off again it's same
kind of thing and King is going all-in
in fact King gives his be on Vietnam
speech he's completely called out he's
just and wcp condemns him and Rustin
comes out against him and what does he
do on April 15th he doubles down he goes
to New York with hundreds of thousands
of people and marches and again he says
that he says a week before he died or a
month before he died what does we are
fools if we are only worried about the
lunch counters were integrating but yet
not the world and protecting the world
in which we integrate it doesn't make
any sense and curette on the same day of
course was in San Francisco at 75,000
others so but yeah I think the communism
peace and protecting that is a piece of
it but that also goes with the Truman
Doctrine and then Reagan doctrine this
constant drawing this line in the sand
of with us or against us and if you're
not you're in the other ear on the other
side
Vincent is you can hear from the steady
array of questions I think we could go
on for hours but this has been a
wonderful talk and we we all thank you
thank you